[Musique]
c'est l'été le beau temps est enfin
arrivé si vous avez envie de passer vos
week end en extérieur les activités ne
manquent pas celui des juniors de cette
semaine se déroule dans un jardin un bon
jour mais l'ami jean camille on va dans
un jardin en fait alors c'est celui de
la maison elsa triolet aragon à
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines ça se passe
dans un parc de 5 hectares le rendez
vous est donné le dimanche 1er juillet à
partir de 14 heures c'est la cinquième
édition de jardins en fête une après
midi poétique et bucolique on écoute un
nombre de la maison triolet aragon
c'est un moment extrêmement touchant
pour nous ce que vous avez savent
toujours justement à la fin du national
scolaire
c'est un moment où on va vraiment
mélanger les arts et on aura donc des
arts de rue avec un piano manège qui
sera installé mais on aura aussi une
pièce de théâtre sur qui nous sont si
durs libre sensibilisera à l'écologie et
les petites mains vont aussi être mises
à contribution et où est-ce qu'après
avoir été spectateurs les participants
seront acteurs alors pas de panique pour
les plus timides ce sont des activités
manuelles qui vous attendent alors avec
l'association sol et vannerie vous
pourrez créer des objets tressés en
fibre végétale ou être des artistes d'un
jour en croquant le paysage avec art
passion les jardins en fête de trial et
triolet aragon c'est donc le dimanche
1er juillet dès 14 heures et puis
n'oubliez pas pour vous inscrire le site
internet www.me son tir est triolet
tirer aragon point com qui s'affiche en
bas de l'écran